[Music]
congratulations on your first movie
kiddo you got to turn that thing off
before we go high I will okay so on
action Sly Bob kicks in the door lights
the place up g g g g yeah no I got it
okay people we go on take of this let's
St mess it up
oh I just heard from the producers and
you're
fired not right now
have a seat make yourself at home is
that your uh foreign car sitting out
little ways out of town got the Harvard
sticker in the window merusi irn could I
get the Wi-Fi we don't have that old
school this is from 2015 things don't
change too much around here we'll get
you back on the road soon enough and
while you're waiting maybe you could
help me
out a bunch holes in the Earth for oil
like a bad B ass there's a million ways
to get hurt on oil rig fall down knock
your teeth out get blown up electrocuted
if a pip falls down it'll kill you I'm
going to step back all right you guys
got it though you know how much
education I got eighth grade day I
dropped out my old dad threw me up on a
rig all I know they're going to take
everything I have and they're going to
ruin me I need you to act like you are
my Harvard educated landman I know all
the landman around here I've never seen
that Jack op in my life check out of
shoes all right we're made up let's
start drilling they S A going to drill
yourself
right this is not where I belong this
acting this is always your dream
yeah we got to find a lease drill it we
got to make a strike in 30 days I think
with your Harvard smarts you can help me
solve this you two keep scheming and
I'll start collecting tips in case I
have to bail you out of
jail
you really are willing to risk
everything yes I am he loves you you
know that right when I get too close he
always ends up drifting away there Comes
A Time one could sure use a little
help there in the
ring
[Music]
Bai